This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We're surrounded by people who tell us they know what's going to happen in the future. A lot of people have no idea that Trump is headed for a historic defeat. Bear Sturz is fine! Don't move your money from there! That's just being silly! These predictions have a few things in common. The commentators have complete confidence in themselves. We as the audience love to hear them make a complicated world seem simple. And finally, no one ever pays a serious price for being wrong.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们周围总有人告诉我们，他们知道未来会发生什么。很多人根本不知道特朗普即将遭遇历史性的惨败。贝尔·斯图尔兹很好！别把你的钱从那里转走！那纯粹是无稽之谈！这些预测有几个共同点。评论员们对自己充满信心。作为观众，我们很喜欢听他们把复杂的世界说得简单明了。最后，从来没有人为犯错付出沉重的代价。
Donald Trump wins the presidency. The country is win the Super Bowl! Brady has his ship! Trump wins the presidency. Their stirs in the bargain bin sold to rival JP Morgan Chase for just two dollars a share. On today's show, our fascination with making predictions and why we may need a revolution in the way we make them. If you play the game the way it really should be played, the forecasting game, you're much more subject to embarrassment. We look at how some people actually are better than others at predicting what's going to happen in the future. Ironically, these aren't the people you usually find on television
唐纳德·特朗普赢得总统大选。这个国家赢得了超级碗！布雷迪拥有他的冠军奖杯！特朗普赢得总统大选。他们的廉价股被以每股仅两美元的价格出售给了竞争对手摩根大通。在今天的节目中，我们将探讨我们对做预测的痴迷，以及为什么我们可能需要对预测方式进行一场革命。如果你按照真正应该玩的方式来玩这个游戏，也就是预测游戏，你更容易感到尴尬。我们来看看为什么有些人实际上比其他人更擅长预测未来会发生什么。讽刺的是，这些人通常不是你在电视上看到的那些
blow-vading about what's going to happen next week. They're ordinary people who happen to know a very important secret. Predicting the future isn't about being unusually smart or especially knowledgeable. It's about understanding the pitfalls and the way we think and practicing better habits of mind. Phil Tetlock is a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania. Over several decades, he's shown that the predictions of so-called experts are often no better than what he calls, dart throwing chimpanzees. After spending years criticizing forecasts and forecasters, Phil decided to look at people
夸夸其谈、对下周会发生什么大放厥词的人。他们是普通人，恰好知道一个非常重要的秘密。预测未来并不是因为你异常聪明或博学多才。而是要了解我们思维中的陷阱和方式，并培养更好的思维习惯。菲尔·泰特洛克是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家。几十年来，他通过研究表明，所谓专家的预测往往并不比他所说的“扔飞镖的黑猩猩”好多少。在花了多年时间批评预测和预测者之后，菲尔决定去研究那些
who were very good at predicting the future. In his book, Super Forecasting, The Art and Science of Prediction, Phil explores how we can learn from these people to become better forecasters ourselves. Phil, welcome to Hidden Brain. So Phil, lots of people watch television at night, and millions of people feel like throwing things at their television set each evening as they listen to pundits and prognosticators, explain the day's news, and predict what's going to happen next. Of all the people in the country, you probably have more cause than most to hurl your coffee cup at the television set because starting in 1984, you conducted a study that analyzed
非常擅长预测未来的人。在他的书《超预测：预测的艺术与科学》中，菲尔探讨了我们如何向这些人学习，从而让自己成为更好的预测者。菲尔，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。那么菲尔，很多人晚上看电视，每天晚上听着专家和预言家解释当天的头条新闻并预测接下来会发生什么时，数百万人都有一种想把东西砸向电视机的冲动。在全国所有人中，你可能比大多数人更有理由把咖啡杯砸向电视机，因为从1984年开始，你进行了一项研究，分析了
the predictions of experts in various fields. What did you find? Well, we found that pundits didn't know as much about the future as they thought they did. But it might be useful before we start throwing things at the poor pundits on the TV screen to consider their predicament. They're under pressure to say something interesting. So they resort to interesting linguistic gambits. They say things like, well, I think there's a distinct possibility that Putin's next move will be on a stonia. Now, that's a wonderful phrase, distinct possibility.
各个领域专家的预测。你发现了什么？嗯，我们发现专家对未来的了解并不像他们想象的那么多。但在我们开始向电视屏幕上可怜的专家扔东西之前，考虑一下他们的困境可能会很有用。他们承受着说点有趣的事的压力。所以他们诉诸于有趣的语言策略。他们会说诸如“嗯，我认为普京下一步行动很有可能会针对爱沙尼亚”之类的话。现在，这是一个绝妙的短语，叫“很有可能”。
It's wonderfully elastic because if Putin does move into a stonia, they can say, hey, I told you, there was a distinct possibility it was going to do that. And if he doesn't, they can say, hey, I told you, there was a distinct possibility. It was going to do that. And if he doesn't, they can say, hey, I just said it was possible. So they're very well positioned. Now, if you play the game the way it really should be played, the forecasting game, and you use actual probability.
它是如此具有弹性，因为如果普京真的进军爱沙尼亚，他们可以说，嘿，我早就告诉过你，他有很大的可能会这么做。如果他没有这么做，他们可以说，嘿，我早就告诉过你，他有很大的可能会这么做。如果他没有这么做，他们可以说，嘿，我早就告诉过你，他有很大的可能会这么做。如果他没有这么做，他们可以说，嘿，我只是说有这种可能。所以他们的立场非常有利。现在，如果你按照真正应该玩的方式来玩这个游戏，也就是预测游戏，并且你使用了实际的概率。
So you play it the way Nate Silver plays it. And you wind up with, say, 70% probability that Hillary will win the election a few days before the election in November 16. You're much more subject to embarrassment. If he said there's a distinct possibility that Hillary will win, he could have been very safely covered. Because when you ask people to translate distinct possibility of the numbers, it means
所以你按照内特·西弗（Nate Silver）的方式来玩。在2016年11月选举前几天，你得出了例如希拉里有70%的概率赢得大选的结论。你更容易感到尴尬。如果他说希拉里有很大的可能会赢，他就能把自己保护得很安全。因为当你要求人们把“很有可能”转化为数字时，它意味着
anything from about 20% to about 80%. I want to talk about how and why people often arrive at the wrong forecast. In your book, you tell the story of a doctor in 1956 who went in to see a dermatologist because he saw spots on the back of his hand. Tell me the story of Archie Cochran. Well, Archie Cochran was one of the early pioneers of evidence-based medicine. He was a great believer in running experiments, randomized control trials, and he was very skeptical of his fellow physicians. He was a great believer in running experiments, randomized control trials, and he was very skeptical
从大约20%到大约80%不等的任何数字。我想谈谈人们如何以及为什么经常做出错误的预测。在你的书中，你讲了一个1956年的故事：一个医生去看皮肤科医生，因为他发现手背上有斑点。请讲讲阿奇·科克兰的故事。嗯，阿奇·科克兰是循证医学的早期先驱之一。他非常坚信应该进行实验、随机对照试验，并且他对同行医生持高度怀疑态度。他非常坚信应该进行实验、随机对照试验，并且他对同行医生持高度怀疑
of his fellow physicians. He thought that they were systematically overconfident in much the same way that my data suggests that political pundits are systematically overconfident. So he was a skeptic by nature. Yet when he did get this cancer diagnosis from an eminent specialist. He didn't wait for the biopsy results to come in.
态度。他认为他们系统性地过度自信，这与我的数据表明政治评论员系统性地过度自信的方式非常相似。所以他天生就是一个怀疑论者。然而，当他真的从一位杰出的专家那里得到这个癌症诊断时。他甚至没有等待活检结果出来。
He just allowed them to go right into surgery immediately before the biopsy, which was a shame because it turned out that he did not have emoligrancy. We use that as an example of the bait and switch heuristic. So Archie Cochran didn't know whether he had cancer, but he was looking in the eye of a very renowned specialist who looked exactly like the sort of person who would know. So he took a really hard question, do I have cancer? And he substituted a somewhat easier question.
他直接让他们立即进行手术，甚至在活检之前，这真是一件憾事，因为事实证明他并没有恶性肿瘤。我们用这个来作为“诱饵转换启发法”的一个例子。所以阿奇·科克兰不知道自己是否患有癌症，但他正面对着一位非常著名的专家，这位专家看起来完全像是那种会知道答案的人。所以他遇到了一个非常困难的问题：我得癌症了吗？然后他用了一个稍微简单一点的问题来代替。
And that is, does this guy I'm talking to right here look like the sort of person who would know if I have cancer? And the answer to that was a resounding yes. So he took the answer to the easier question. He assumed it applied to the harder question and he forged ahead and got massive surgery that proved to be unnecessary when the biopsy results came in.
那就是：我正在和这个人说话，他看起来像是那种知道我有没有得癌症的人吗？而这个问题的答案是一个响亮的“是”。所以他接受了那个更简单问题的答案，并假设它适用于那个更困难的问题，于是他直接推进并做了大规模手术，而当活检结果出来时，证明这是完全不必要的。
Archie Cochran didn't make that mistake again. He went on to have a very distinguished career where he developed a series of techniques to help doctors guard against the pitfalls of following their intuitions. He said, look, you might be very smart, you might know a lot, but there's something you have to do
阿奇·科克兰没有再犯那个错误。他开启了一段非常卓越的职业生涯，在此期间他开发了一系列技术，帮助医生防范因顺从直觉而陷入的陷阱。他说，听着，你可能非常聪明，你可能知道很多事情，但有些事情你必须在
before you act on your intuitions. This did not make him popular with his fellow doctors. Right. And Cochran now is honored, but I think during his lifetime, a lot of his colleagues, Tom, is a pain in the butt. He would run experiments that would repeatedly show that the intuitions of his colleagues were off base. There was a debate, for example, among cardiologists about how long heart attack patients should stay in the hospital after the heart attack, and whether the mortality would be higher if they went home or if they stayed in the hospital. And the conventional
根据直觉采取行动之前做。这并没有让他受到同行医生的欢迎。没错。科克兰现在受到了人们的尊敬，但我认为在他生前，他的许多同事都觉得汤姆是个讨厌鬼。他会进行实验，一次又一次地表明他的同事们的直觉偏离了方向。例如，心脏病专家之间曾有过一场辩论，关于心脏病发作的患者在发作后应该在医院住多久，以及如果他们回家或者留在医院，死亡率是否会更高。而心脏病专家中的传统
wisdom among cardiologists was that it was better for them to stay in the hospital. But Cochran said, look, we have to test our intuitions. People would be happier, it would be less expensive, and so forth, if people were resting at home. And they thought that would be a terribly unethical experiment to run, because it could kill people, right? If it showed that the people getting the home rest were actually dying at a higher rate. But Cochrane persisted.
观点认为，让他们留在医院会更好。但科克兰说，听着，我们必须检验我们的直觉。如果人们在家休息，他们会更快乐，成本也会更低，等等。他们认为进行这样一个实验是非常不道德的，因为它可能会死人，对吧？如果结果表明在家休息的人死亡率实际上更高的话。但科克兰坚持了下来。
He wasn't a guy to take no for an answer, and they ran the experiment. And he also had a mischievous streak. So he presented the results to those two colleagues, and he flipped them around. He showed them a chart that indicated that the heart attack patients who went home were dying at a higher rate, just as the conventional wisdom predicted. And the doctors were outraged.
他不是那种会接受“不”作为答案的人，他们进行了实验。而且他也有顽皮的一面。于是他把结果呈现给那两位同事，并把结果颠倒了过来。他向他们展示了一张图表，显示回家休养的心脏病患者死亡率更高，正如传统观点所预测的那样。医生们对此感到愤怒。
They said, Archie, we told you you're a fool. Look what you've done. You've caused great harm. You've got to stop this experiment immediately. And then he paused and he mischievously smiled. caused great harm, you've got to stop this experiment immediately. And then he paused and he misdivously smiled and he said, oh, I got the data turned around. It turns out that the people who are going home are living longer. The truth is, making predictions is difficult, but many biases also get in the way of making
他们说，阿奇，我们告诉过你你是个傻瓜。看看你做了什么。你造成了巨大的伤害。你必须立即停止这个实验。然后他停顿了一下，调皮地笑了笑。造成了巨大的伤害，你必须立即停止这个实验。然后他停顿了一下，顽皮地笑了笑，说道，哦，我把数据弄反了。事实证明，回家的人活得更长。事实是，做预测是很困难的，但许多偏见也阻碍了我们做出
accurate forecasts. When we make a prediction and it turns out wrong, most of us don't remember that we predicted something different. In fact, the hindsight bias prompts us to believe we'd gotten it right all along. We also hail people who make predictions that turn out right, whether in this talk market or politics or sports, but that keeps us from seeing the role of luck. Many people who get the right answer are just lucky, and some people who get's wrong are just unlucky.
准确的预测。当我们做一个预测结果却证明是错误的时候，我们大多数人都不记得自己曾预测过不同的结果。事实上，后见之明偏见促使我们相信自己从一开始就预测对了。我们也会为那些预测正确的预测者欢呼，无论是在股市、政治还是体育领域，但这让我们忽视了运气的角色。许多得出正确答案的人只是运气好，而一些得出错误答案的人只是运气不好。
Over time, the laws of probability mean luck can only take you so far. One reliable way to check if someone's success at predictions is driven by skill or by luck, is to have them make lots of predictions and see how they turn out over time. A few years ago, the federal government launched such an experiment. They conducted a forecasting tournament where thousands of people logged into computers to make thousands of predictions.
随着时间的推移，概率规律意味着运气只能带你走到这一步。检验某人在预测方面的成功是由实力驱动还是由运气驱动的一个可靠方法，是让他们做出大量预测，并看看随着时间的推移结果如何。几年前，联邦政府发起了一项这样的实验。他们开展了一场预测锦标赛，数千人登录电脑做出了成千上万个预测。
As time passed, the forecast could be checked for accuracy. It was a remarkable thing for the professional career government officials to do, to sponsor a project that had the potential to be embarrassing. We were one of five academic research teams that were competing to pull together the best methods of making probability estimates of events that national security professionals cared about. What kind of questions were they asking? All over the map quite literally. security professionals cared about. What kind of questions were they asking?
随着时间的推移，可以对这些预测的准确性进行检验。对于职业政府官员来说，资助一个有可能令人尴尬的项目是一件了不起的事情。我们是竞争整合出对国家安全专业人员关心的事件做出概率估计的最佳方法的五个学术研究团队之一。他们当时在问什么样的问题？可以说是五花八门。国家安全专业人员关心的事件？他们当时在问什么样的问题？
All over the map, quite literally. So there would be questions about violent clashes in the east or south China Sea. There would be questions about the Syrian civil war, about Russian-Ukrainian relations, about the Iranian nuclear program, Columbia Narco-Trafikers, literally all over the map. So you found, at some time, that people who were not necessarily trained experts in a specific domain were actually able to perform as well, or maybe even better than people who were the experts? Yeah, that's essentially right.
可以说是五花八门。所以会有关于东海或南海暴力冲突的问题。会有关于叙利亚内战、俄乌关系、伊朗核计划、哥伦比亚贩毒集团的问题，可以说是五花八门。所以你有时会发现，那些不一定是在特定领域受过专业训练的专家，实际上能够表现得和专家一样好，甚至可能比专家还要好？是的，基本上是这样的。
David Ignatius broke the story, I think, in 2013 in the Washington Post about how the best forecasters in the Good Judgment Project are outperforming professional intelligence analysts who had access to classified information, and we're working on an internal prediction tournament. How could this be? Are these people smarter than the rest of us? More knowledgeable? When we come back, I'll talk to Phil about what makes a super forecaster a super forecaster. Stay with us. If you were asked to pick someone to answer a difficult question about the
大卫·伊格纳蒂斯（David Ignatius）我想是在2013年《华盛顿邮报》上发表了一篇报道，讲述了“良好判断项目”中最好的预测人员如何表现得优于能够获得机密信息并参与内部预测锦标赛的专业情报分析师。这怎么可能呢？这些人比我们其他人更聪明吗？知识更渊博吗？稍后回来，我将与菲尔讨论是什么让超级预测者成为超级预测者。请继续收听。如果你被要求挑选某人来回答一个关于
economy or foreign affairs, you might turn to an Oxford-educated public intellectual who writes a column for a very important newspaper. You probably wouldn't turn to a retiree in Nebraska who spends his time bird watching. But Filtaht Lock says, maybe you should. He was the opposite of Tom Friedman in the Superforecasting book. Tom Friedman, of course, being an eminent New York Times columnist, a very, very elegant writer, best-selling author, well-known for his explanations. But nobody has any idea how good a forecastry is.
经济或外交事务的难题，你可能会去找一位牛津受过教育的公共知识分子，他为一份非常重要的报纸撰写专栏。你可能不会去找内布拉斯加州一个把时间花在观鸟上的退休人员。但菲尔·泰特洛克说，也许你应该这么做。他在《超预测》一书中是汤姆·弗里德曼的反面。汤姆·弗里德曼当然是《纽约时报》杰出的专栏作家，一位非常非常优雅的作家、畅销书作家，以其深入浅出的解释而闻名。但没有人知道他的预测能力究竟有多好。
And Bill Flack is an anonymous, retired irrigation specialist working in Nebraska, working out of the public library, or out of his home, and doing a fabulous job, making probability estimates in the good judgment project in the intelligence community forecasting tournament. So you helped discover Bill Flatt. Was he part of your team that you entered in this forecasting tournament? He was indeed. He was one of the very best. The very best forecasters in the tournament were called out each year.
而比尔·弗拉克（Bill Flack）是内布拉斯加州的一位匿名退休灌溉专家，在公共图书馆或家里工作，在情报界预测锦标赛的“良好判断项目”中做出了极其出色的概率估计。所以你帮助发现了比尔·弗拉克。他是你带入这场预测锦标赛的团队成员吗？他确实是。他是最优秀的选手之一。锦标赛中最优秀的预测者每年都会被点名表彰。
The top 2% and we put them into elite teams called super forecasting teams. And we let them work together. And they did just a fabulous job. Super forecasters like Bill Flack turn out to have some things in common. Tell me about the kinds of philosophies they have and the kinds of thinking styles that you seem to find in common among many of these super-forkasters. I would say the most distinctive attribute of the super-forkasters
前2%的选手被我们编入被称为超级预测团队的精英团队中。我们让他们一起合作。他们做得非常出色。像比尔·弗拉克这样的超级预测者身上有一些共同点。跟我讲讲他们拥有的哲学种类，以及你似乎在许多这些超级预测者身上发现的共同思维方式。我会说超级预测者最显著的特征
is their curiosity and their willingness to give the idea a try. And when I say the idea, I mean the idea that forecasting is And when I say the idea, I mean the idea that forecasting is a skill that can be cultivated and is worth cultivating. Because it doesn't matter how intelligent you are, or how knowledgeable you are, if you believe that it's
是他们的好奇心以及他们愿意尝试新想法的意愿。当我说这个想法时，我的意思是预测是一个可以培养的技能，并且值得去培养的想法。因为不管你有多聪明，
essentially impossible to get better at these kinds of tasks, you're never going to try, and it's never going to happen. It's as simple as that. So a big necessary condition for moving forward is having the attitude that this is a skill that can be cultivated and is worth cultivating. SuperForkasters tend to gather information and update their beliefs in a very particular way. Filthat Lock points to Aaron Brown, the chief risk officer of the hedge fund AQR. Before he was a big shot in finance, he was a big shot in the world of poker. He was a world-class poker player. And we quote him as saying that you can tell the difference between a world-class poker player
或者你有多博学，如果你认为在这些类型的任务上变得更好基本上是不可能的，你将永远不会去尝试，而这种事情也永远不会发生。就是这么简单。因此，向前迈进的一个重要必要条件是拥有这样一种态度：这是一项可以培养且值得培养的技能。超级预测者倾向于以一种非常独特的方式收集信息并更新他们的信念。菲尔·泰特洛克提到了对冲基金AQR的首席风险官亚伦·布朗（Aaron Brown）。在他成为金融界大人物之前，他是扑克世界的风云人物。他曾是世界级的扑克玩家。我们引用他的话说，你可以区分出世界级扑克玩家
and a talented amateur. Because the world-class player knows the difference between a 60-40 bet and a 40-60 bet. In any pauses and said, oh, maybe like 55, 45, 45, 55. Distinguishing more degrees of maybe is an important skill. Why is that? Well, the very best forecasters are well calibrated. So when they say events are 80% likely, those events happen about 80% of the time.
和天才业余选手。因为世界级玩家知道60-40的赌局和40-60的赌局之间的区别。他停顿了一下说，哦，也许就像55对45，或者45对55。区分更多程度的“也许”是一项重要的技能。为什么会这样？嗯，最好的预测者都经过了很好的校准。所以当他们说事件发生的概率为80%时，这些事件大约有80%的概率会发生。
When they say things are 90% likely, they happen about 90% of the time. So it makes a difference how frequently you update your forecasts. If you don't update your forecasts reasonably frequently, you're going to fall out of phase with events. And that means often making adjustments that are relatively small. You suggest that forecasters should do something that doesn't seem to be very intuitive. Instead of looking at the particulars of an individual case, you say forecaster should zoom out and figure out how often something has happened historically. So Daniel Conhamen is probably one of the greatest psychologists of the last hundred years,
当他们说事情发生的概率为90%时，它们大约有90%的概率会发生。因此，你更新预测的频率会产生影响。如果你不以合理的频率更新预测，你就会与事件脱节。这意味着通常需要做出相对较小的调整。你建议预测者做一件看起来不是很直观的事情。你没有去观察单个案件的细节，而是说预测者应该缩小视角，弄清楚历史上某事发生的频率有多高。所以丹尼尔·卡尼曼（Daniel Kahneman）可能是过去一百年中最伟大的心理学家之一，
and he calls that the outside view. And he says, people rarely take the outside view when they do forecasting. They normally start from the inside and they work out, but there's a big advantage to you as a forecaster from starting with the outside view and working in. Take another example, let's say you're out of wedding and you're sitting next to somebody who has the bad taste to ask you how likely to think it is this couple is going to stay married? And you look at the person, it's bad taste and all that, you see how happy the couple is and you can see it's a joyous occasion, you say, I can't imagine these people who are so happy together getting divorced,
他称之为“外部视角”。他说，人们在做预测时很少采用外部视角。他们通常从内部开始并向外推导，但作为预测者，从外部视角开始并向内推导有很大的优势。再举个例子，假设你参加一个婚礼，你坐在一个品味糟糕的人旁边，他问你这对夫妇能维持婚姻的概率有多大？你看着这个人，觉得这太没品了，你看到这对夫妇有多幸福，你能看出这是一场欢乐的场合，你说，我无法想象这两个在一起这么快乐的人会离婚，
I think maybe a 5% chance they're going to get divorced. Now, if you ask that question of a super forecaster, they'd say, well, what's the, let's look at the sociodemographics of the couple and let's see, what's the base rate of divorce within this socio-demographic group? Let's say it's 35 or 40 percent over the next 10 years. Okay, I think it's about a 40 percent chance to get divorced in the next 10 years. Now, that's not the end of the forecasting process. That's just the beginning. The real value, though, of doing it this way, of starting from the outside and working in, is it puts you in the ballpark of plausibility right away. 40% is a much more plausible number than 5%. Now then you could start adjusting the 40%. So if you discover things about the couple that suggest they really are
我觉得他们离婚的几率大概是5%。现在，如果你把这个问题问给一个超级预测者，他们会说，嗯，这对夫妇的社会人口统计特征是什么，让我们来看看在这个社会人口统计群体中离婚的基准率是多少？假设在未来10年内是35%或40%。好吧，我认为在未来10年内他们离婚的几率大概是40%。现在，这并不是预测过程的结束。这只是开始。然而，以这种方式行事的真正价值，即从外部开始并向内推进，在于它能立即把你带到一个合理的范围内。40%比5%要合理得多。现在你就可以开始调整40%这个数字了。所以如果你发现这对夫妇的某些地方表明他们真的
deeply bonded to each other and they've known each other a long time and they really understand each other and they've done great things for each other, you're going to lower your probability. If you discover that the husband is a sociopathic philanderer. You're going to lower your probability, if you discovered that the husband is a sociopathic philanthropist, you're going to raise the probability. Those are inside view sorts of pieces of data that would cause you to adjust. Or you might just see that having a small fight and say, well, OK, I'm going to move from 40 to 41%.
彼此深度绑定，他们认识很长时间了，他们真正理解彼此，并且为彼此做了很多伟大的事情，你就会降低你的概率。如果你发现丈夫是一个反社会的花花公子。如果你发现丈夫是一个反社会的慈善家，你就会提高概率。这些是内部视角的各类数据，会促使你进行调整。或者你可能只是看到他们正在进行一场小争吵，然后说，好吧，那我把概率从40%调整到41%。
And that's one of the interesting things of a super forecast is they do a lot of updating in response to relatively small events. And most of the news, one of the interesting things of a super forecast is they do a lot of updating and response to relatively small events. And most of the news, most of the time, is what statisticians would call low diagnosticity news. It doesn't change things dramatically, but it does change things a little bit. And appreciating how the news gradually builds up toward one conclusion or another is a very valuable skill.
这就是超级预测者的有趣之处之一，他们会针对相对较小的事件做出大量的更新。而且大多数时候的大多数新闻，超级预测者有趣的一点是他们会针对相对较小的事情做出大量更新。大多数时候的大多数新闻，都是统计学家所说的“低诊断性新闻”。它不会戏剧性地改变事情，但确实会改变一点点。理解新闻如何逐渐累积导向某个结论，是一项非常宝贵的技能。
I'm wondering if one reason many of us start with the inside view rather than the outside view, is that just at an emotional level, that's how our minds think, that you see a couple, and you put yourself in the shoes of that couple, and you try and imagine what's happening in their lives, and we think in stories, and we imagine what life must be like for that couple, and we're trying to see
我在想，我们很多人从内部视角而不是外部视角开始的原因之一，是否仅仅是在情感层面上，我们的思维就是这样运作的，你看到一对夫妇，然后你把自己代入这对夫妇的角色，你试着想象他们生活中发生了什么，我们用故事来思考，我们想象这对夫妇的生活会是什么样子，我们试图去看看
how that story will turn out, and we're trying to follow the narrative where it leads rather than do this much more, you know, abstract remote process of saying, let me start with the rough estimate of how often something happens. There's something about that in some ways that requires us to step outside this narrative frame that we often use to understand the world. I couldn't put it better. I think that's right. We're quite readily seduced by stories. Another example might be, it comes from research and this is again related to Daniel Coniman and his work on the conjunction fallacy. It's another source of error and forecasting. Let's say I ask you, how likely is it that in the next 10 years there'll be a flood in North America that
这个故事会如何发展，我们试图跟随叙事的发展方向，而不是去做这种更加抽象、遥远的过程，即：让我从某个事情发生频率的粗略估计开始。在某种程度上，这需要我们跳出我们经常用来理解世界的叙事框架。我再怎么赞同也不为过了。我认为这很对。我们很容易被故事所吸引。另一个例子可能来自于研究，这再次与丹尼尔·卡尼曼及其关于合取谬误的工作有关。这是预测中的另一个错误来源。假设我问你，在未来10年中，北美发生一场洪水并
kills more than 1,000 people and ask you to make an estimate on that. Let's say I ask another person to make the estimate. How likely is it that there'll be a flood in California that will be caused by an earthquake cracking a dam leading to a massive outflow of water? Now, when I put the two questions together like that, it's pretty obvious that a flood
导致超过1000人死亡的概率有多大，并请你对此做出估计。假设我让另一个人做出估计。由于地震导致水坝破裂并引发大量水流，加利福尼亚发生洪水的概率有多大？现在，当我把这两个问题放在一起时，很明显，由于任何原因
anywhere in North America, due to any cause, has got to be more likely than a flood in California caused by an earthquake cracking a dam. The California event is obviously a subset of the more general North American flood thing. But people don't see it that way. The California earthquake dam story is more like a story. It's like a story. You can actually put it together in a more meaningful way, whereas a flood anywhere in North America is kind of abstract and vague.
在北美任何地方发生洪水的概率，一定比由于地震导致水坝破裂而在加利福尼亚发生洪水的概率要大。加利福尼亚的事件显然是更普遍的北美洪水事件的一个子集。但人们不这么看。加利福尼亚地震水坝的故事更像是一个故事。它就像是一个故事。你可以用一种更有意义的方式将它拼凑在一起，而北美任何地方发生洪水则显得有点抽象和模糊。
So people can transport themselves into the world, and you can imagine it's like a movie, like a Hollywood movie playing out. And they can see it happening. Yes, I can see that happening. And in fact, I can see it as you're speaking right now, Phil. And that pumps up the probability and that screws up your forecasting track record. So again, think of forecasting as a skill that can be improved with practice. When you're making a prediction, start with the base rate, the outside in view. Beware of the risks
所以人们可以把自己带入那个世界，你可以想象它就像一部电影，一部好莱坞电影正在上演。他们可以看到它发生。是的，我可以看到它发生，事实上，菲尔，就在你说话的时候我就能看到。这拉高了概率，并搞砸了你的预测记录。所以再次强调，把预测视为一项可以通过练习不断提高的技能。当你做预测时，从基准率开始，采用由外向内的视角。当心
of storytelling. Finally, amateurs make three kinds of predictions. Yes, no, and maybe. Professionals have many gradations of maybe, and the attached specific probability estimates to their predictions, allowing them to go back and learn where they went wrong. But even if you do all these things, I asked Phil how you can be really sure that predictions that turn out correct are because of good technique. You know, there's an old trick that they play in business schools to talk about the role of luck where they divide the class into pairs and they say, you know, have a coin toss between each person and then the winner of each of those coin tosses competes against another winner
讲故事的风险。最后，业者做出三种预测：是、否和也许。专业人士有许多不同程度的“也许”，并将具体的概率估计附加到他们的预测中，使他们能够回过头来了解他们在哪里出错了。但即使你做了所有这些事情，我问菲尔，你如何能真正确信那些被证明正确的预测是因为采用了好的技术呢？你知道，商学院里流传着一个关于运气作用的老把戏，他们把全班同学分成两两一组，然后说，让每个人之间进行抛硬币，然后每一次抛硬币的赢家与另一个赢家竞争
and after 12 rounds there's one person who has who has declared the winner and of course that person in a business sense might seem to be extraordinarily good but really all that's happened is they've happened to win 12 coin tosses in a row they've just been very lucky. How do you distinguish between people who are lucky and people who are actually very good? Well that is indeed the $64,000 question and it comes up in finance too. I mean there are some finance professors out there who would argue that the really famous super investors were in Buffett or Ray Dalio and people like that. Aren't some sense like coins that come up heads 20 or 30 or 40 times in a row.
在经过12轮比赛后，会有一个人被宣布为赢家，当然从商业角度来看，这个人可能会显得异常优秀，但实际上发生的一切只是他们连续12次抛硬币都赢了，他们只是运气非常好。你如何区分那些走运的人和那些真正非常优秀的人？嗯，这确实是一个价值6.4万美元的问题，在金融领域也会遇到这个问题。我的意思是，有些金融教授会认为那些真正著名的超级投资者不是巴菲特或雷·达里奥（Ray Dalio）这样的人。在某种程度上，不就像是连续20次、30次或40次抛出正面的硬币吗？
We have a lot of people competing in financial markets, and they're making a lot of predictions over long stretches of time. So you're going to expect some streaks. And when we get really streaky performance, we declare we found a genius. So the skeptics would say, well, Phil Tetlock is doing essentially the same thing here. He's anointing people who are essentially lucky.
我们在金融市场上有很多人在竞争，他们在很长一段时间内做出了大量的预测。所以你会预期会出现一些连胜。当我们看到非常具有连胜性质的表现时，我们就会宣称我们找到了一个天才。所以怀疑论者会说，嗯，菲尔·泰特洛克在这里做的事情基本上是一样的。他在册封那些本质上只是运气好的人。
So we built in a lot of statistical checks, but you can never be 100% sure. One of the other critiques of Phil's work is that the kinds of questions that super forecasters are answering are not really the questions that people want answered. Most of us are interested in the big questions. Who's going to win the current standoff
所以我们内置了许多统计检验，但你永远无法百分之百确定。对菲尔工作的另一个批评是，超级预测者回答的问题并不是人们真正希望得到答案的问题。我们大多数人对宏观大局感兴趣。谁将赢得当前
between the United States and Russia? Super forecasters tend to answer much more narrow questions. Is Russia going to invade Ukraine in the next 18 months? I think that's a very fair criticism of the first generation of forecasting tournaments that we put all of our effort into improving forecasting accuracy. Now, I'm not going to say the questions that people were trying to answer were trivial because they were by no means trivial. As a way, no means trivial, whether Russia was going to invade the Ukraine or the Syrian civil
美国和俄罗斯之间的僵局？超级预测者倾向于回答范围小得多的问题。俄罗斯会在未来18个月内入侵乌克兰吗？我认为这是对我们投入全部精力来提高预测准确性的第一代预测锦标赛的一个非常公平的批评。现在，我并不是说人们试图回答的问题是微不足道的，因为它们绝非微不足道。在某种程度上绝非微不足道，无论是俄罗斯是否会入侵乌克兰，还是叙利亚内战是否会像现在这样拖得如此惨烈漫长等等。我的意思是，这些问题确实是非常重要的事情。但它们是否涉及公共政策视角下最重要的事情？我们能否让这些问题与深层的政策问题更加相关？我认为答案是肯定的。科学是循序渐进的。你一次只做一件事。所以这第一代预测锦标赛产生的结果是，证明了存在着一项值得培养且可以培养的技能。
war was going to drag out as horribly long as it has and so forth. I mean, the questions were really important things. But were they about the things that matter the most from a public policy perspective? Could we have made the questions more relevant to deep policy questions? I think the answer is yes. Science proceeds incrementally. You do one thing at a time. So what these first generation of forecasting tournaments generated is that there is a skill that is worth cultivating and can be cultivated.
好吧，这是第一步。现在我认为下一代锦标赛应该专注于你在这里所说的事情。我认为我们应该同样关注问题的深刻性以及答案的准确性。我在想，有些问题是不是太难预测了。如果我们是在1917年而不是2017年进行这番对话，有人会告诉你，你知道的，现在这个国家有40%的人口从事农业，而从现在起的一百年后，这个国家只有2%的人口从事农业。
Okay, that's step one. Now I think the next generation of tournaments should be focusing on exactly what you're saying here. I think we should be focusing as much on the insightfulness of the questions as the accuracy of the answers. I'm wondering if some questions just are too hard to forecast. We were having this conversation in 1917 rather than 2017 and someone would tell you, you know, 40% of the country right now is in farming and in 100 years from now, 2% of the country would be farming.
得出这样的结论是合理的：这个国家很大一部分人将失业，我们的失业率将达到35%-40%。这是一个完全合理的结论。当然，当时根本没有办法完全理解这种情况是如何没有发生的。我在想，在某些方面，超级预测的意义是否在于将问题分解得如此简单，以便他们能够准确地回答问题，但这不一定是重要的问题。有个关于一个在街上丢了硬币的家伙的旧笑话，他在路灯下找硬币，因为那里最亮，而不是他真正丢硬币的地方。这就是我们在用超级预测做的事情吗？
It would be reasonable to conclude that a good chunk of the country would be out of work that our unemployment rate would be 35%-40%. And that would be a perfectly reasonable conclusion to draw. And of course, they just would be no way to fully understand how that would not have come to pass. And I'm wondering in some ways, is the point of super forecasting to break questions down so that they're so simple, so that they're answering questions with accuracy, but not necessarily questions that are of importance. old joke of the guy who loses a coin on the street and he searches for the coin under the street lamp because that's where it's brightest, not where he actually dropped the coin. Is that what we're doing with super forecasting?
有没有可能我们问的是那些最容易回答、最容易附加这些概率估计的问题？但只要你再稍微推进一步，我们本质上就是在瞎猜。嗯，你提出了大量有趣的问题，我会第一个同意你的看法，即预测锦标赛可能会退化成琐事追求游戏。我也非常赞同你的前提，
Is it possible that we are asking the kinds of questions that are the easiest to answer, the easiest to which we can attach these probability estimates? But the moment you go a little bit further out, we essentially are just guessing. Well, you've raised a host of interesting questions, and I would be the first to agree with you that forecasting tournaments can degenerate into games of trivial pursuit. And I'd also agree very much with your premise
即当你试图对地缘政治和地缘经济重大问题做出超过10年以上的预测时，预测的准确性实际上会下降到概率水平，也就是扔飞镖的黑猩猩的水平。所以这两点都是真的。预测的时间范围是有限的。而且确实，如果你不仔细挑选问题，
that forecasting accuracy falls virtually to chance, to the dark throwing chimpanzee, when you try to forecast more than about 10 years out on geopolitical and geoeconomic questions of consequence. So both of those things are true. There's a limit on the forecasting horizon. And it's true that forecasting tournaments, if you don't pick the questions carefully,
使它们汇聚成重要的事情，预测锦标赛就会变得微不足道。所以这两点都是真的。我不认为这意味着我们不应该进行预测锦标赛。我认为我们应该把预测锦标赛做好。我要问你最后一个问题。这也是我认为对超级预测的一个潜在批评，但它是以我将要做出的一個预测的形式出现的。我认为我们许多人之所以做预测，或者指望预言家和评论员来做预测，是因为它让我们觉得我们对未来有一种掌控感。
so that they add up to something important, they can become trivial. So both are true. I don't think that they mean we shouldn't be doing forecasting tournaments. I think that we should be doing forecasting tournaments as well. I'm going to ask you one final question. And this is also I think a potential critique of super forecasting, but it comes in the form of a forecast that I'm going to make. The reason I think many of us make forecasts or look to prognosticators and pundits to make forecasts is that it gives us a feeling like we have a handle on the future.
它给我们一种安心感。这就是为什么自由派喜欢看MSNBC上的评论员，而保守派喜欢看福克斯新闻上的评论员。一种更为谨慎的风格，比如声称唐纳德·特朗普被弹劾的几率是11.3%，或者你死于癌症的几率是65.3%。这些估计违背了我们对确定性的强大心理冲动，我们实际上希望有人握着我们的手告诉我们“你不会死”。我们不想要概率估计。
It gives us a sense of reassurance. And this is why liberals like to watch the pundits on MSNBC and conservatives like to watch the pundits on Fox. A more cautious style that sort of says, the chance that Donald Trump is going to be impeached is 11.3% or the chance that you're going to die from cancer is 65.3%. These estimates run up against a very powerful psychological impulse we have for certainty that we actually want someone to hold our hand and tell us you're not going to die. We don't want a probability estimate.
我们实际上希望得到事情会如我们所愿发展的保证。所以这是我对你的最后一个问题。如果有人建议人们做一些违背他们对幸福和安心的情感需求的事情，我预测这个建议，无论出于多么良好的意愿，无论多么准确，很可能不会被大多数人采纳。你对我的预测有什么看法，菲尔？嗯，我认为你所说的话中有很多真实之处。我认为人们在思考未来时，有很多目标，他们希望确认自己对意识形态阵营的忠诚。
We want actually an assurance that things are going to turn out the way we hope. So here's my last question for you. If someone advises people to do something that runs against their emotional need for well-being and reassurance, I'm going to forecast that that advice, however well-intention, however accurate, is likely not going to be followed by most people. What do you make of my forecast field? Well, I think there's a lot of truth to what you say. I think people, when people think about the future, they have a lot of goals, and they want to affirm their loyalty to their ideological tribe.
他们希望对过去的承诺感到良好。他们希望强化自己的先入之见。所以这些都是人们在做预测时拥有的所有社会和心理目标。而预测锦标赛是一个非常不寻常的世界。我们创造了一个只有一件事重要的世界：纯粹的准确性。所以这在某种程度上类似于
They want to feel good about their past commitments. They want to reinforce their preconceptions. So those are all social and psychological goals that people have when they do forecasting. And forecasting tournaments are very unusual worlds. We create a world in which only one thing matters. It's pure accuracy. So at somewhat analogous to the sort of world
金融市场、伦敦博彩公司或拉斯维加斯博彩公司所创造的世界，唯一重要的是金融市场、伦敦博彩公司或拉斯维加斯博彩公司所产生的赔率的准确性。我会这么说。我会说，如果人们对自己信念所发挥的功能更加诚实，他们会过得更好。我之所以相信这一点，是因为它有助于我与朋友或老板相处、有助于我融入集体、有助于我对自己感觉良好，还是因为这确实是对现有最佳证据的最佳综合？如果你在参与
is created in financial markets, or London bookies, or Las Vegas bookies, all that matters is the accuracy of the odds created in financial markets or London bookies or Las Vegas bookies. All that matters is the accuracy of the odds. I would say this. I would say people would be better off if they were more honest with themselves about the functions that their beliefs serve. Do I believe this because it helps me get along with my friends or my boss, helps me fit in, helps me feel good about myself or do I believe this because it really is the best synthesis of the best available evidence. If you're playing
预测锦标赛，只有后一点才重要，但你是对的，当人们坐在起居室里观看他们最喜欢的评论员时，他们是在为自己的团队欢呼。那是另一种心理学。他们在玩一种不同的游戏。所以我所说的一切只是，如果你对自己正在玩什么游戏保持诚实，你会过得更好。心理学家菲尔·泰特洛克是《超预测：预测的艺术与科学》的作者。菲尔，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。
on a forecasting tournament it's only the latter thing that matters, but you're right when people sit down in their living room and they're watching their favorite pundits, they're cheering for their team. It's a different kind of psychology. They're playing a different kind of game. So all I'm saying is you're better off if you're honest with yourself about what game you're playing. Psychologist Phil Tatlock is the author of Superforecasting, The Art and Science of Prediction. Phil, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
不客气。音乐 本周的节目由雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）、勒内·克拉尔（René Clarre）和帕思·沙阿（Parth Shah）。我们本周的无名英雄是来自我们营销团队的波西亚·罗宾逊-米加斯（Portia Robinson-Migas）。波西亚在《隐藏的大脑》创立初期帮我们集思广益了许多点子，并一直是一个坚定不移的朋友。谢谢你，波西亚。你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上找到我们，
My pleasure. MUSIC This week's episode was produced by Raina Cohen, and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Penman, René Clarre and Parth Shah. Our unsung hero this week is Portia Robinson-Migas from our marketing team. Portia helped us brainstorm many ideas in the early days of hidden brain and has remained a steadfast friend. Thanks Portia. You can find us on Facebook, Twitter, and Instagram
也可以每周在你当地的公共广播电台上收听我的故事。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。你 本集节目目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
and listen for my stories each week on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请每周在您当地的公共广播电台收听我的节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是美国国家公共电台。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。